e
house will come to order the chair
recognizes a member from marburn
represented marsman Whooves the house
adjourn in the session of February 6
2025 you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those Close n the
eyes have it and the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a Prayer by
house chaplain Reverend Jonathan Hopkins
conquer good
morning since President's Day is coming
up this morning's prayer incorporates
the words of George Washington and
Abraham
Lincoln dear God today we bring the
needs of our government before you and
ask you to bless our state through these
elected leaders we give thanks that they
have heard the call to serve all the
people of the great state of New
Hampshire we pray for the members of the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
to find peace and Direction and for
these men and women to act and Lead
according to wisdom and Justice A house
divided against itself cannot stand
therefore we pray for them to be unified
in righteousness for the sake of our
state remember this morning that Beyond
politics we care for one another as
humans and we pray this morning for rep
Gabby Grossman's son Oscar that you will
be with them in this difficult time we
stand here today on the shoulders of all
other men and women who have served in
our government before us remember today
the prayers of President George
Washington that thou will incline the
hearts of the citizens to cultivate a
spirit of subordination and obedience to
government and entertain a brotherly
affection and love for one another and
for their fellow citizens of the United
States of America at large and finally
that thou will most graciously be
pleased to dispose us all to do justice
to love Mercy
and demean ourselves with Charity
humility and a Pacific temper of Mind
remember today the words of President
Abraham Lincoln with malice toward none
with charity for all with firmness in
the right as God gives us to see the
right let us finish the work we are in
to bind up the nation's wound to care
for him who shall have borne the battle
for his widow and for the orphans to all
which may achieve a cherish and just and
Lasting peace among ourselves and with
all other nations be with the New
Hampshire House of Representatives today
to continue the work of the great state
of New Hampshire that serves to bring
amen chair recognizes a member of marac
group General Julie miles who will lead
allegiance I to the of the United States
of America and the IT stand
na
indivisible and justice for
all the chair recognizes Tristan Plum of
Anthem say can you see
by the dawn's
early
light what so
proudly we
hail at the
Twilight last
gleaming who brought stripes and bright
fight or the ramp parts we
want where so
gallantly
streaming and the
glare the bombs
air came
Pro through the
night that our flag was still
there oh say does that Star
Spangled
way for the
free and the
home of
the bra
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
representatives gagy and lungren the day
important business Representatives
William Dolan Dupont and John McDonald
the day illness in the family
Representatives Crawford and Grossman
these leads of absent shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Marissa Clump student of the
virtual Learning Academy Charter School
our Paige for the
[Applause]
day Mr Speaker please welcome Elise and
Peter Rolo guests of Representative
miles Elizabeth Spain Foss guest of
Representative Foss the honor hble
Michael McCarthy and Peggy McCarthy
former members from NASA guests of
Representative ducet executive
counselors Karen Leo Hill and Janet
Stevens guests of the speaker they are
house the house will attend to a
resolution
Mr Speaker Representatives Osborne and
Simpson offer the following resolved
that the House of Representatives notify
the honorable Senate that it is ready to
meet in joint convention for the purpose
of hearing the budget addressed by Her
Excellency Governor Kelly
aot the question is on the adoption of
the resolution are you ready for
resolution are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have the
resolution is
adopted the house will attend to a
wa
e
for
Miss
the house will attend to a senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate is ready
to meet with the honorable House of
Representatives and joy convention for
the purpose of hearing the budget
addressed by Her Excellency the governor
Kelly
aot house will come to order the chair
[Applause]
[Music]
Arms Mr Speaker president of the Senate
honorable Sharon Carson of Londoner
[Applause]
order the chair recognizes the Sergeant
at Arms
Mr Speaker Her Excellency Governor Kelly
aot
[Applause]
The Joint convention will be attentative
Aon Mr Speaker speaker Madame President
honorable members of the House and
Senate counselors Commissioners my
fellow citizens our state is on a
remarkable upward trajectory and today
I'm here to present my recommended
budget for fiscal years 2026 and
2027 which will keep us on the path to
Greater prosperity for all of New
Hampshire We Begin this year with our
economy in a very strong position
our rate of job growth exceeds the
national average and is the best in New
England new business startups also
exceed the national average unemployment
is low wages continue to rise and we are
outperforming our neighbors in so many
different
measures our New Hampshire Advantage is
on display for all to
see our prudent financially responsible
approach to taxes and regulations and
our commitment to protecting our unique
quality of life has made us a prime
destination in the region in the
competition for
talent as individuals assess their
opportunities and families look at the
the cost and quality of life New
Hampshire is seen as a
destination where you can re realize
your full
potential what we've created over these
last number of years is special
and all of New Hampshire is benefiting
from it this success does not come
without new
challenges like increasing our housing
Supply or having a best-in-class
education system or keeping up with the
demand for our
services but I believe together we can
meet these challenges head
on when I stood here a month ago I
shared with you the necessity for us to
recalibrate I told you that we must
operate within our means and meet our
commitments to those who are depending
on
us and for the past number of years our
budgets have been bolstered by billions
of dollars from the federal government
due to the covid
pandemic we've also seen High revenues
that made it easy to engage in Surplus
spending in new areas
our last budget saw a
21% spending increase in general funds
over a two-year period not to say
anything of the off-budget spending that
occurred as well the simple fact is that
our Revenue landscape looks different
from that of the past number of years
with Federal transfers dropping and
revenues lower lower
overall a recalibration of our approach
is in
order both for the total amount of
spending and also for how we Steward
every single taxpayer
dollar the state of New Hampshire is
strongest when we as individuals
families and small businesses have more
money in our pockets that's something
that our friends on the other side of
the strength of our state lies in the
individual in those that create the job
job
opportunities for others that isn't the
role of
government furthermore the answer to our
challenges is not to take more from our
citizens in the way of taxes but rather
to look carefully and thoughtfully what
what at what we're doing as a
state ask if we need to be doing it ask
if we can afford to continue doing it
much of what we accomplish best in our
state is done at the local level and
that's why we are pushing more funds
than ever to the local level and it's
why I also challenge our local officials
to take the same stance we do as a State
and to take a hard look at what they're
level thank
[Applause]
you when we're sending more monies money
down locally I would hope that our local
officials would accordingly pass on
property Le relief tax relief whenever
it's possible in building this budget
our guiding principle has been to
deliver a budget worthy of our people
that represents a re-calibration of the
way we do business while continuing our
New Hampshire way of not raising taxes
but instead taking a hard look at
spending we have a constitutional
responsibility to deliver a balanced
budget for the citizens of New Hampshire
we rolled up our sleeves to find savings
to meet this mandate and our
commissioners work diligently alongside
of
us in comparison to our last budget we
are spending $150 million less in
general funds in this budget
[Applause]
this adjustment in general funds was
undertaken smartly and thoughtfully with
a scalpel not a shovel it does so
without across theboard cuts and
prioritizing those who are depending on
the services provided by the state we we
focused on making our government more
efficient and ensuring that tax dollars
do more with
less we cut bloated contracts from out
of state vendors we took a hard look at
how our agencies operate and we worked
with our commissioners to dial in
spending we also found areas to make
responsible adjustments that bring us in
line with the times and we followed What
other states are doing as well as well
we brought our Medicaid Eligibility back
in line with prepandemic levels and
joined our neighbors in requiring
nominal co-pays for some of those
receiving those
benefits I'd like to thank our
commissioners for their diligence in
working through this process and their
openness to considering new ideas and
approaches to our
work those who depend on the services of
our state
can rest assured that this budget will
deliver for
them Rising costs are a problem for
everyone and we heard loud and clear the
need to help our local communities meet
the needs of
tomorrow I am proud to announce that
this budget sends more money down to the
local level and spends more money on
education than ever before
[Applause]
this budget also Begins the overhaul of
the group two retirement system to make
good on our promise to those who keep
our state safe it delivers record levels
of spending for special education nearly
50% % higher than the last
[Applause]
[Music]
vium this budget expands education
freedom to all public school students
[Applause]
this budget will help get the cell
phones out of the classroom it continues
a tuition freeze at our community
colleges it ensures no weight list for
persons with
disabilities it streamlines the
permitting process for housing and it
does a whole lot more
this budget not only honors our
unbreakable commitment to those in need
of our help but it will help prepare our
next Generation to meet the needs of
tomorrow as
well what we have done for our students
in this budget is
tremendous we are spending more on
education than ever before and we're
putting our students and our teachers
first this budget continues the
increases from the last bium and it
ensures that our education system has
the resources that it
needs we are making a
98.8 million investment in speal special
education nearly a 50% increase from the
[Applause]
we understand the Skyrock skyrocketing
cost facing towns in providing special
education and we want to lessen the
financial burdens and ensure that
students are receiving the resources
that they need we are making education
Freedom available to all public school
students so that parents can decide what
learning environment is best for their
children and that every child can reach
his or her full potential in our great
[Applause]
state and we're making good on my
promise to get the cell phones out of
the schools but we're doing it we're
going to do it the New Hampshire way
there's a million dollar in this there's
a million dollars in this budget
available for Grants to school districts
to come up with their own Solution on
how to address the cell phones in the
schools and some schools are already
taking this action on their own at
Stevens High School in Claremont they've
given every student a secure pouch to
lock in their cell phone at the
beginning of the day and at the end of
the day they get their cell phone back
let me tell you what the results of that
are this policy is reducing distractions
in the classrooms it's great for
students it's great for teachers it's
also reducing cyber
bullying and it's doing it all without
[Applause]
police we are making investments in our
community college system to keep career
ready education accessible to our
students ensure that our businesses have
a Dependable pipeline in the trades and
other high demand jobs so that we have
the workforce of tomorrow here in New
Hampshire we are investing $4.4 million
to ensure tuition stays flat at our
community colleges to make sure that
that opportunity to attend a community
college is accessible to as as many
students as possible we are putting $6
million toward dual and concurrent
enrollment programs giving students the
opportunity to jumpstart their careers
in high school whether by making it
faster and cheaper for them to receive
necessary training for the career they
want or giving them the exposure and the
experience earlier to discover their
passion and to build their confidence to
go for it 10,000 students across our
state are taking advantage of these
programs and collectively it represents
millions of dollars in savings for them
and for their families and also helps
them chart a good course for their
future we are also funding expansions
for Career and Technical education and
our Workforce credentialing programs
which make it easier for individuals to
get training they need for the in-
demand jobs in our state from the trades
like wealth and HVAC and electrical work
to the important healthc care Workforce
like licensed nursing
assistance just last week I heard a
story of Lindsay Taylor a mom of two who
wanted to change careers and she wanted
to give back to her community she
entered a short-term credentialing
program to become an LNA at
nhti and after passing the licensing
exam you know where she went to work she
went to work in dementia care at the
Marram County Nursing Home Lindsay is an
incredible example of an individual who
was able to answer her
calling and use the pathway created by
these credentialing programs we want
everyone who feels that pull to have the
same opportunity in our
state investing in these opportunities
for students to learn a trade or get
credentialed in a high demand and field
like healthcare is going to pay
dividends in the long run for the State
of New Hampshire and for our citizens by
opening new Pathways to public private
Partnerships addressing critical gaps in
our
Workforce and putting more Granite
Staters on the path to having a really
good paying career right here in our
great
state last month at my
inaugural I spoke to you about
service and how important service is to
my
family and how important it is that our
state that we Foster that Spirit of
service across our state that we teach
it that we model it so that our kids
grow up and they want to serve
themselves as
well those that serve others in New
Hampshire are truly the backbone of our
state our law enforcement our
firefighters our EMTs our Corrections
Officers First Responders nurses
teachers state employees National Guard
members our citizen
legislature service can take on so many
different forms in our state but it is
the Bedrock of our
state those public servants they protect
us they take care of us they defend us
they teach us they help lead us their
contrib utions to our communities cannot
be properly
valued and that's why it's so important
to me that when it comes to our Public
Safety employees that they have a fair
and competitive retirement system to
ensure that we can recruit and retain
those who have these dangerous jobs
[Applause]
[Music]
which is why I am proud to announce that
today we are starting the process of
overhauling our group two retirement
system by making a $33 million
investment to restore the benefits that
were promised to our Public Safety
employees it's the right thing to do
[Applause]
[Music]
this is only the beginning but it is a
big step forward in ensuring that they
receive the retirement that they have
earned our ranking as the safest state
in the nation is a result of the work of
our dedicated First
Responders our state troopers our
Corrections Officers our local police
our Deputy sheriffs our firefighters our
probation and parole
officers we depend on them and they
depend on us to make sure that they have
the tools that they
need and that begins with sending me
legislation to fix this this disastrous
bail law that is putting our law
enforcement officers at risk and the
[Applause]
large what happened in Manchester last
Friday night it's
unbelievable when an individual accused
of repeatedly
stabbing another person in the middle of
Elm Street I think those of us know
where Elm Street is on Main Street where
all those businesses and stores are and
this person also had a prior conviction
for domestic violence but was allowed to
walk free by a
magistrate I cannot emphasize this
enough send me legislation to fix this
[Applause]
all this budget ensures our law
enforcement have the tools and resources
necessary to keep our state safe it
fully funds the granite Shield
initiative which is combating fenol
methamp fet mean now xylazine Statewide
and funds the creation of a new Northern
Shield effort that will bring more
resources to Coos Grafton Carol and
Sullivan counties to combat drug
trafficking it also helps support uh
this effort that we are undertaking with
the City of Lawrence to stop the flow of
drugs that are coming up 93 and into our
state it adds an additional
full-time investigator to the attorney
general's Cold Case unit to bolster
their resources in cracking these cases
and providing closure to the victims of
these very difficult
cases it provides $10.5 million to
fulfill our victims of crime
obligations $2.3 million for courta
appointed special Advocates $3 million
for child advocacy centers
and nearly a million dollars to help the
internet crimes against children task
force and as our nation
struggles uh with the impacts of illegal
immigration here in New Hampshire we
have created a northern border Alliance
which is a deterrent on our northern
border I've heard directly from law
enforcement the North country our
federal Partners members of our Coos
County
delegation and local res
residents everyone who lives up there
and you know what they tell me the
response is resounding this program is
working that's why we're going to
continue to fund it and we're going to
continue to let them work to secure our
northern border and keep New Hampshire
safe
[Applause]
one of my critical responsibilities as
Governor is to provide for our most
vulnerable citizens who depend on the
state for their daily
needs our first step in shaping this
budget was to protect the programs that
those who are most most in need rely on
which is why we're we've secured over a
billion dollars for in the banum to fund
services for Citizens with developmental
[Applause]
disabilities from transportation to
medical appointments to physical therapy
programs to other
services we are ensuring those with
disabilities in our state have the
support system that they need I'm also
proud to say today that this budget will
ensure there continues to be no
[Applause]
[Music]
Hampshire I said in my inaugural address
that those seeking treatment for mental
health challenges it's just as important
if you're if you have a mental health
challenge to seek treatment as it is
when you break your leg uh and you go to
the doctor to help you with that or
you're
sick my budget will support the
continued efforts to strengthen our
[Applause]
we have
added $10 million for the uncompensated
care provided by our community mental
health uh centers who do such important
work in helping Granite Staters uh who
are struggling with mental health issues
and make sure that they get the care
that they need New Hampshire will also
continue to lead the way and giving a
hand up
to our citizens who are seeking
treatment and recovering from a
substance use
disorder this budget fully funds the
recovery friendly Workforce program so
that we can continue to ensure that
working through recovery is not a
barrier toward Economic Opportunity in
our
state there is no greater pressure
Weighing on the economic success of our
state right now
than the housing market and the
challenges we're facing there Supply is
tight demand is high and inventory is
expensive our economic success hinges on
our ability to attack attract talent and
given the great story we have to tell
we're succeeding people are coming but
they need an affordable place to live in
New Hampshire we also need to com combat
this affordability crisis is so that our
kids stay so that our retirees stay so
that our communities keep old faces and
welcome new
faces our job growth leads the region
but today home listings are half their
pre-pandemic levels and rentals are
extremely tight not to mention higher
home prices rents mortgage rates all of
which has gone
up and it makes it even harder
I believe that the first step we can
take as a state to help our housing
market is to be good models of the
change that we would like to
see this starts with streamlining our
permitting process to get Builders
answers faster so that the projects are
not unnecessarily hung up in
bureaucracy which is why I'm announcing
a plan to streamline the permitting
process to ensure that it takes no more
than 60 days and puts the burden on the
state to meet this timeline or to
Forfeit the right to
act this is a first step in ensuring
that we are a good actor as a state and
it sets a model for local communities to
follow as we respond to the critical
housing shortage that we face as a state
but let me be clear about something we
aren't going to meaningfully address
prices or loosen our supply unless our
local communities are coming to the
table and recognize the role that each
of those communities also played in our
shared
success what we have
here in New
Hampshire um it's working but we need to
all work together on this housing issue
to make sure that there's more supply
for our
state the more we can share what we're
doing in New Hampshire the more it is
good for our state and for our people
it's important for us to understand what
we're doing well as a state in the
context of our
neighbors and as I said early earlier
our job growth leads the
region and it's our ability to attract
talent to our state that is really to
thank for our economic
success we cannot be shy about telling
the story about what we're
doing which is why I felt it was so
important to keep funding going to
promote our state encourage tourism and
spread the gospel of the New Hampshire
way and since we're on the subject of
what draws others here our natural
beauty as a state is both one of our
points of Pride but it's more than that
it is the Bedrock of our unique quality
of life here in New
Hampshire to me it's pretty common sense
to say that our North Country our Lakes
Region our beautiful Open Spaces
throughout this state shouldn't be
scarred by poorly envisioned projects
that detract from our quality of life
which is why I am announcing today a
landfill moratorium and a revamped
regulatory process for approving these
projects coming forward to ensure that
[Applause]
compromised and lastly before I close I
want to mention again one of my new
initiatives the commission on government
efficiency as we call it the cach coach
a coach will be working diligently to
develop new ideas on how our state can
become even better like past Governor
appointed commissions to improve
government operations we brought in
outside experts and we're bringing in
new thinking and
ideas I look forward to reviewing their
recommendations in the coming months as
they thoughtfully consider ways that we
can improve government on behalf of the
people of New Hampshire and deliver for
the people of this
state in
conclusion our state remains in an
enviable
position to maintain our standing as the
beacon of the
Northeast and to adjust to the revenue
environment we're facing some
recalibrations they're in order but we
have been thoughtful
and taking care to ensure that they will
not be felt by those who are most
vulnerable and who need
us this budget is a step forward for our
future and it will help us directly
address the challenges we face in
growing New Hampshire in growing our
prosperity and our
freedom this is truly a budget for All
of New Hampshire I want to thank you for
listening this morning may God God bless
you and your important work and may God
bless the great state of New Hampshire
[Applause]
representative Osborne and Senator BS
will move that the joint convention
arise are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those who oppose
nay the eyes have it and the joint
thank you Mr Speaker it's always a
is going to take the chairs out right
now so let's just wait one minute
order recogniz Isaac clerk thank you Mr
Speaker I have a letter from the chair
of the finance committee Mr Speaker
pursuant to house rule
47f House Bill 127 and House Bill 480
finance the house will now attend to the
consent
calendar Mr Speaker there are no bills
to be removed from the consent
calendar are there any other bills
movement consent calendar pres wbon
moves at the consent calendar with the
relevant amendments printed in today's
house record be adopted are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose nay the eyes haven't
the consent calendar is adopted under
rules of the house from the committee on
education policy and administration
House Bill 677 is referred to the
committee on finance the committee on
environment and agriculture House Bill
FNL is referred to the committee on
criminal justice Justice and Public
Safety from the committee on Municipal
and County government HB 165 FN it's
referred to the committee on finance
from the committee on Transportation HB
612 FN is referred to the committee on
finance house now attend to a regular
calendar
majority of committee on labor
industrial and realtive services to
which is referred House Bill 238 FN an
act prohibiting collective bargaining
agreements from requiring employees join
contribute to a labor union been
considered the same report the same with
a recommendation to Bill ought to pass
sen Michael Granger for the majority of
the
committee minority other committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Mark
committee for what purpose does a member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I move in
I recogniz to speak to that motion
Representative Steven Pearson to speak
to his motion thank you Mr speaker thank
friends I rise today to move inde
238 there's been a tremendous amount of
misinformation on this issue
lately so let's look at some
facts not sound bites from 10 years ago
ago but facts for
today right to work is no longer in the
Republican National
platform it was removed by President
Trump you can look it up for yourself if
gone Trump's nominee for the Secretary
of Labor Chavez D rier and I apologize
to her if I butchered that is BR Pro
labor and anti-right to work there have
been dozens of Articles published on
this
fact including ones that indicate her
nomination may be
Rocky if right to work was a concern
then why did President Trump nominate an
secretary another fact Trump invited the
president of the seamsters to speak at
the RNC
convention vice president Vance spoke at
the firefighters convention in
Boston the reality is since gianis
changed you cannot make America great
right to work is pushed primarily by a
group called Americans for
Prosperity they are an anti-trump
organization he has tweeted about this
multiple
following we will make America great
again and it will happen very quickly in
order to save time money and effort it
would be helpful
if you would not send or recommend to us
people who work with or endorsed by
Americans for Prosperity that is taken
directly from Trump's Twitter
feed many of you support right to work
because you feel that someone should not
have to join a union to get a job I
completely and totally agree with
that but it is already current
law RSA
275.000 no person shall coers or compel
or attempt to coer or compel any person
into an agreement either written or
verbal to join or become a member of any
labor organization as a condition of
securing or continuing in any employment
RSA
2751 it was enacted in
1949 it has been law for over 75 years
so if that's your concern your concern
has been
met at this year's New Hampshire GOP
convention a resolution was passed
affirming the GOP support for American
workers union and non-union it passed
almost
unanimously no one campaigned on this
issue in fact it is not even in the top
20 of Republicans
surveys all it's doing is alienating
Working
Families right to work is a
concept of hollow unfulfilled promises
West Virginia passed it the Republican
governor was clear all the promised jobs
never showed up Oklahoma passed it and
all it did was lower
wages it is a failed concept of a bygone
era pushed by an organization whose
influence and relevance is rapidly
disappearing it is time for New
Hampshire to look
forward solve actual problems the voters
care about and end this pointless attack
on Working
Families thank you Mr
Clark thank you Mr
Speaker just just a quick question Mr
Speaker is this Deja Vu or
vuja for some of the newer members in
the house it's probably vuja because
they've never heard this before but for
the rest of us it's definitely Deja Vu
we've all been here with this
legislation many times for some many
many many times because it's first
introduced to this house somewhere in
the mid 70s and since we are not a right
to work state has been voted down with
bipartisan support again and again since
its Inception on January 22nd the labor
committee which just happens to be the
best house the best Committee in the
house Mr Speaker we heard over 5 hours
of testimony for and against right to
work we heard lots of facts and support
of from groups like New England citizens
for Right to Work Americans for
Prosperity and the jiah Bartlet Center
for Public Policy just to name a few one
fact that we heard was right to work is
supported by nearly 80% of the citizens
of New Hampshire I would agree with that
it might even be a bit higher everyone
believes that people have the right to
work but when we asked if the bill was
described to people as the union busting
bill that it is yes or no we got the
world run
around we were told that it was
described differently in different polls
depending on who was being pulled so in
other words no how do I know that that
number might be skewed a bit because of
the approximately 1500 people that
testified in person or online on hearing
day less than 100 were in support now I
know it's been a while since I was a
crusader at Manchester Memorial High
School graduating in the top 400 of my
class but that does not add up to 80% it
7% another fact we heard was that many
businesses are lining up to come to New
Hampshire as soon as we become a right
to work state when we ask for examples
of said companies we were told that it
was a
secret but just last year Governor
sonunu said that many businesses are
coming to New Hampshire New Balance just
built a 100,000 ft building in Londoner
and a 500,000 ft building is going up in
Hudson I'm constantly seeing stories of
groundbreaking ceremonies at the Tuscan
Village in Salem where new businesses
are either coming in or existing ones
are growing and we are still not a right
to work state one more quick fact that
we heard was union members are forced to
pay dues as a condition of employment
not only is that against the law but not
one not one of the union members that
testified in opposition of this Bill
said that they were being forced to pay
dues we asked they are voluntarily
paying I've worked for many good
non-union companies for many years but
none could commit to the paying benefits
that the Carpenters offers so I chose to
join the same exact work for better
wages and benefits now I asked now now
because of the dues that I pay
voluntarily what I put in has already
come back to me many times over and will
continue through my retirement years
unless this bill passes once again I
would wager my entire 2-year legislative
salary that many of you have left a job
for a better opportunity
elsewhere like me not everyone is made
for college of the military Mr Speaker
but many are good with their hands the
carpenters in all of the Building Trades
have apprenticeships real New Hampshire
certified apprenticeships not just
banging this nail okay you're a
carpenter no the coers create their own
Workforce and great employees by
investing millions of dollars offering a
four-year program where apprentices
learn many facets of construction from
foundations to
finish at no cost to them in buildings
paid for by the members not through your
property taxes or state funding
thousands of apprentices and Journeymen
are trained at our training centers
every year think about it they earn
while they learn so instead of owing 140
,000 after four years of college they
potentially made
$140,000 and nothing says that they have
to stay in the union once their training
is complete helmet the hard hats a group
that places veterans in apprenticeships
to start a new career after serving has
the Carpenters and Building Trades on
speed dial I'd hate to see that
opportunity that has helped so many be
lost through the passage of this bill I
understand that some of you have had a
bad experience with the Union you may
may be disgruntled because of that bad
experience I get it not every day for me
is perfect in any way but I chose to
stay with it keep it knowing that it
would the the the bad would be um
outweighed by the
good please remember that union members
are members of our communities they live
in our towns pay their taxes and
frequent our local businesses some are
small business owners themselves the
union subc Contra that I work for is out
of Hudson New Hampshire they chose to go
have been in business for over 40 years
one of the owners is a union carpenter
as was his dad and now so is his son
they're a family-owned women-owned
business that has created millions of
hours for their Union employees over the
years and the labor committee which just
happens to be well you know Mr Speaker
it is said that almost every meeting
that we should not get between a
business owner and their
employees let's not start
now coer is another building trade
volunteer their skills to many great
causes I've personally participated in
at least three makea wish progress
projects for some very sick kids and as
many Wounded Warrior or other veteran
causes building new homes for Our Heroes
that served these members are yours and
my
constituents Mr Speaker esteem
colleagues I apologize if I seem a bit
nervous or on edge up here today but I
assure you it's not because I'm up here
speaking in front of all of you it's
because all of you are deciding my
future and the futures of thousands of
union members if this deal if this bill
does not pass it will affect no one I
believe that to be true because I've
never heard of any business going under
because of right to work did not pass if
it does the families of approximately
one in 10 of our constituents including
me and many uning companies will be
negatively affected after busting my ass
on construction sites for over 40 years
freezing in the winter sweating in the
summer I'm looking to finally retire in
about 6 months but my pension and the
pension of many others may be in
Jeopardy why because if this legislation
goes through people will be able to join
a union without contributing so I ask
you how long do pensions last with no
money going in like many Union families
I'm relying on my pension to last for
the rest of my and Francine my wife life
please join me in indefinitely
postponing this mislabeled misleading
union busting Bill once again because
you all know in your hearts that right
to work is and always will be wrong for
New Hampshire thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to
indefinite postponement of HB
238 this bill is not anti-union it is
pro-worker this bill is part of the GOP
platform HB 238 is vital to Fair
Employment Practices workers and
employers should have the option to
negotiate their own employment
agreement we owe it to our businesses
to hear these
arguments I urge you to join me in
opposition to the motion by pushing the
much representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that M does the
question thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you represent
kraton um would you
believe that after bidding on a project
I had to create a union company in order
to complete our work and that without
forming a union company my family would
have suffered drastically along with all
workers yes ma'am I would believe that
representative seren we has a requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is indefinite
postponement on House Bill 238 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
Representative Steven Pearson for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know right to
work has been removed by President Trump
from the national Republican platform if
I know it has been illegal in New
Hampshire to force someone to join a
union to get a job since 1949 and if I
know that we cannot make America great
again if we don't support American
workers then please support our trades
folks and our Working middleclass
Families and vote green on a definite
postponement thank
you Jer organized representative POA B
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that bad legislation being on the books
is a reason to fix it instead of
accepting the status quo if I know that
the
state GOP State platform supports ending
Force unionism if I know that public
sector unions have continued to thrive
since the 2018 J Supreme Court decision
and so will private unions after we end
forced unionism if I know that no person
who wants to be a union member will be
affected in any way but the people who
don't want to join a union will benefit
making this a win-win for New Hampshire
if I know that many union members are
unhappy with the performance of their
union leaders but have no practical way
to influence them if I know that passing
this bill will give union members more
power leading to unions stop you know to
stop taking their members for granted
and what present them and lastly Mr
Speaker if I know that our governor and
15 out of 24 colleagues from across the
worldall publicly stated they support
giving workers the freedom to choose
whether they want to join a union or not
well I press the red button so we can
make history today by finally winning
fight the motion before us is inev of
postponement on House Bill 238 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
KH you can't push the button you got to
down all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote you want voting a the house will be
in
[Applause]
order the house will be in order or I'll
chamber seeing I never got a chance to
finish the A's are 200 the Nays are 180
passes representative Dennis Manion
declared a conflict and refused himself
vote majority of committee on Municipal
and County government to which is
referred House Bill 346 FN act relative
to licens your fees for raise tracks
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sen of Dennis Murphy for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to
legislate Dale Gerard for the minority
of the committee are you ready for the
question all those the motion before us
is a to pass on uh House Bill 346 FN are
you ready for the question all those in
nay division has been requested members
I've been six I've
been represent parshall seat please take
the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 346
this is a clarification vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
[Music]
represent
sopus thumb up or down
please represent did I have have the
vote if all M president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 183 voting aay 185 voting aay the
pass
EXC the motion is inexpedient to
legislate so the motion before us now is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
346 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
183 the majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development to
an act extending the closing date of
ohrv trails on the Connecticut River
headquarter property from September 30th
to Columbus Day having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
pres ronal Davis from the majority of
the committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
as inexpedient to legislate
representative will will Darby for the
minority of the committee chair
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker hb27 is
a classic example of legislative
overreach it usurps you local control
ignores long-standing precedent and
pushes a legislative solution to a local
problem that is a clear answer without
without additional
statute it is an overreaction to a
single decision made last year this bill
allows a 10- mile tract in the vast
Connecticut lake Lakes headquarters to
re remain open to off-road vehicles
commonly called ATVs or ohvs until
Columbus Day which seems completely
reasonable until we consider the
background and other options in May of
2024 the Connecticut Lakes Headwater
citizens committee a broad group of
local stakeholders adopted an updated
5-year management plan that carefully
balances the many varied uses of this
Forest including hunting hiking bike
riding ATV riding and many others during
the public hearing on this management
plan there were no requests no requests
to extend the traditional ATV riding
season which concludes on a September
30th this is an important date to avoid
dangerous accidents between speeding
ATVs and hunting dogs used by grous
hunters that visit the North country
from across New Hampshire and the
country while the season is several
months long Hunters focused on the first
few weeks of October and Hunters I spoke
high-speed ATV use that they have
observed this is one of the reasons New
Hampshire fishing game oppos this bill
in addition to the concern of reduced
staff availability to patrol these
trails with the opening of small game
season not only were there no requests
to to extend ATV rioting while
developing the management plan the head
of trails for the Department of Natural
and cultural resources testified that
the trail riding period can be extended
by a petitioning commissioner by to
April 1st which allows for local public
input as required by the conservation
easement between the state and land
owners of the forest this bill likely
violates that conservation easement
which puts all public access to this
private Forest at risk this bill also
ignores Solutions this very body
established to resolve conflicting
interests of ATV
use just three years ago in 2022 HB 1188
established a commission to propose OS
legisl legislation to identify
compromises between the positive and
adverse effect of O RVs the very chair
of the of that commission sponsored this
bill rather than building consensus
within the ohrv commission against the
legislative intent of HB 1188 please
join me in preserving local control
retaining the Integrity of the
Connecticut Lakes Headwaters
conservation evenement promoting tourism
that comes with worldclass G grous
hunting in the North country and
supporting the body's intent of the ohrv
commission by voting against the OTP
motion so that another motion um can be
made that allows us to resolve this
local problem without addition
overreaching statute thank you Mr
Speaker Jer Rec andiz the representative
ronal Davis for
uh
speak thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker House Bill 127
is a very simple bill but one that has
great economic impact on the North
Country this bill will extend the
closing date of 10 miles of OHV Trails
on the Connecticut Headwaters property
from September 30th to Columbus Day
which is approximately two weeks to
align this with the rest of the trails
in the
area there are approximately 110 miles
of trails on private property in
Pittsburgh just north north northwest of
these 10 Mi of connector trails in
approximately 900 mil of
trails to the
South as you can imagine when the
connected trails are closed down two
weeks earlier than the rest of the
trails it land loocks the town of
Pittsburgh from its business community
in the rest of the
state these two extra
weekends represents $3 million in
economic impact to the area
state the town of Pittsburgh has a
population of 800 residents but a a busy
weekend like Columbus Day there there's
no problem having 5,000 people in town
now fishing game claims they do not have
the Manpower or the money to patrol this
10m section of trail for OHV use for the
additional two
weeks they are paid to patrol 1,000 M of
trails around this section until
Columbus Day and to actually Patrol this
section also just up until September
30th fishing game are also already in
the entire area because of bird hunting
season they claim it will not be safe
for hunting in OHV use simultaneously on
these 10 miles of trails but it is
allowed on the other 1,000 Mi of trails
this makes no
sense the Coos County Commissioners have
set money aside in their budget to pay
the sheriff's department to patrol this
10 Mile parcel of land for the
additional two weeks so there will be no
cost to the state and no cost efficient
game the chair of the commission to
study ohrv use in New Hampshire is in
support of this bill he took a straw
pole whole stating the majority of the
commission supports this bill the land
owner of the Connecticut
headquarters property does not oppose
this
bill it is supported by the commiss the
business community of Pittsburgh
including their select board all three
County Commissioners all nine state
representatives our Senator councelor
Pittsburgh's local business owners tried
several times to extend the closing date
for the additional two weeks with no
success in frustration of a broken
system this bill was
introduced to be honest this is actually
not an nov bill it is a bill to support
the economic development of our
neighbors to the north and I urge you to
the division has been requested members
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 127 this is a division vote
chair recognize representative Ryan for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that there's a process in
place for this to happen that was
circumvented and this bill usurps local
Authority if I know there are several is
questioning about bird hunting and can
bird Hunters coexist with their
expensive dogs and the noisy vehicles I
would push the red button to eliminate
this unnecessary legislation thank you
Mr Speaker chair recogniz representative
inquiry thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker
if I know the economy of the town of
Pittsburgh is in dire need of this
bill and if I know that passing this
bill will add no extra cost to the state
or to fishing game and if I also
know this will actually bring much
needed Revenue to the state in the form
of gas tax and room and meals tax would
I then press the green button to vote
out to pass thank you motion for us is
ought to pass on House Bill 127 this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppose you press the red button voting
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 198 voting aay 180 voting aay the
adopted everybody stay in your seats the
next one is going to be a division vote
debate majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development to
which was referred House Bill 174 act
increasing the minimum weight of a
utility terrain vehicle to 3,500 lb
unladen dry weight consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass Vel Davis from
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Suzanne Vale for the minority of the
[Music]
J recogniz representative NAB for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the New Hampshire Timber
Owners Association the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau and the New Hampshire
Wildlife Federation all oppose this
legislation and if I know that this bill
will likely result in spillover of
heavier Vehicles onto private property
creating increased conflict and the
potential for more private land to be
close to ohrv use and while electric Ohr
vehicles are heavier because of their
batteries it is not yet clear how
frequently they are currently being used
would I then push the red button so
another better motion can be made and I
request a division vote thank you you
already thank you chair recognizing
in thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker House Bill
174 again is a very simple Bill actually
it's a housekeeping
Bill representative it's a parliamentary
inquiry oh if I know okay
sorry about that if I Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill will pave the way
for electric
ohvs that's the reason for the weight
change and if I know that electric ohvs
will bring will be a very good thing for
this sport by reducing noise in
emissions would I press the green button
ought to pass the motion before says
ought to pass on House Bill 174 this is
a division vote you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button Ving stations
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
vote 188 voting a 190 voting a the
motion fails
representative moves it representative
Veil moves it t l are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
it majority of the committee on
resources and Recreation development to
which was referred House Bill
203 an act relative to Coast Guard
approval approved Personnel flotation
devices while on New Hampshire state
Waters consider the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Tanya Donley from the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with a recommendation that the
bill ought to pass reprentative Susan
Vil for the minority of the
committee representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is meting to legisl
House Bill 203 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're oppos you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
toner all members present have an
opportunity to vote how tend to state of
the
vote 215 voting a 162 voting a the
for motion chair recognizes the clerk
for a
motion Mr Speaker representative beler
moves that all necessary house rules be
so far suspended as to allow late
Drafting and introduction of a house
bill excuse me a house resolution
relative to the effect of the
Johnson representative beler moves to a
rule suspension and is recognized to
speak to his motion thank you Mr Speaker
good morning
everyone I rise this morning to meet the
challenge of our times headon we find
ourselves in a situation in New
Hampshire where our newly minted bail
system is undermined by extreme
maladministration in
office on February 7th a 25-year-old man
a violent criminal with recent and prior
criminal violent convictions allegedly
stabbed a stranger more than a half
dozen times in Manchester he was
arrested and charged police requested he
be held without bail which is in
accordance with the laws passed by this
body instead he was released on personal
recognizance only hours after this
alleged
incident this represents an extreme
dereliction of Duty imprudence and is
disqualifying from
office we have seen a wave of these
sorts of things happening across the
country especially in our
cities violent offenders loosed on an
unsuspecting
public to be clear it was not a wave of
viral incomp confidence that spread from
coast to coast it was a wave of viral
ideology that placed the comfort of
criminals over the safety of
citizens we have seen the result from
coast to coast is blood flowing in the
streets be it incompetence or activism
either way we cannot allow this virus to
spread here in New
Hampshire to be clear some have
suggested we we need to reform our barar
laws do we need to reform our barar laws
maybe but no law we can craft will solve
the underlying problem in this
issue both the executive and the
Judiciary have discretionary Authority
built into their constitutional
duties the problem here is not exactly
the law that exists the problem is the
way that discretion was utilized in a
malicious
manner no reform we pass can solve that
problem and when we try to do more and
more reforms that take away that
discretion the inevitable result is we
will eventually wind up sending decent
people to prison who don't really have
to
go the way we solve this problem is by
addressing the root cause of it we
expect good decisions good discretion
and Prudence from our
Judiciary when they do not or will not
exercise that we have a duty in this
body to affect a removal from office
that thereby establishes a precedent and
consequences for that kind of
thing the Constitution gives us this
burden nobody
else we are responsible lives quite
literally hang in the
balance I would request you vote green
and I would ask for a roll call vote
thank
you chair recognize representative
Shear thank you Mr Speaker um I'm going
to take the unusual approach of giving
you factual information about what
happened
uh um the initial aggressor in this uh
matter was the alleged victim
he's the one who struck first he hit the
person who is now the alleged defendant
first uh the the defendant
said well I have a knife and the victim
said well I have a knife too and struck
again and then the uh the defendant Mr
Bisson pulled out a pocket
knife and then a tussle ensued and uh
both were
injured uh when Mr Bisson was uh saw the
magistrate he was in the
hospital he was released he then went to
an arraignment on Monday in Manchester
District
Court where the prosecution the
Manchester Police Department had the
opportunity to to ask that Mr Bon be
detention the Manchester Police
Department police prosecutor did not
make that
request that says everything you need to
know about the quality of the case
against Mr Bisson and the soundness of
the Judgment by magistrate
Johnson uh the judge who was the judge
at the arraignment who is not known as
being favorable to defendants continued
the personal recognizance bail asked
that Mr Bon go to the police department
uh to be booked because he wasn't booked
when he was first saw the magistrate
because he was in the hospital he
appeared there and was booked and that's
the case this is not the horror that
people that we know uh have uh made it
to be this is a simple fight between two
people instigated by the alleged victim
and now the defendant has an excellent
self-defense case as both the magistrate
look reflected and the district court
judge so I ask you to vote press the red
no chair recognize represent
Barry uh thank you I will be brief uh
with with all due deference to the
representative from West Morland the
representative was not there a man was
released on cashless bail for stabbing
someone nine times in the middle of
you representative belter asked for a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is suspension of
the roles this is going to be a roll
call vote takes 2/3 to
pass if you're in favor you you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house the state of the
vote 199 voting nay 176 voting nay the
motion fails lack of
two3 Representative Eric Johnson recused
vote okay we're going to break for lunch
now and clerk has one announcement one
Lun announ one lunchtime announcement
announcement thank you Mr Speaker for
those members of the fish and game
committee we will be moving to to l307
our room right now for the beginning of
lunch we will be moving into executive
session on HB 545 HB 589 and HB 202 the
1:00
e
the majority of the committee on
resources Recreation development to
332 an act allowing for the
establishment of a village District to
protect and remediate surface waters
having considered the same report the
same with the fallowing resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representa Pierre Dupont for
the majority of committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with a recommendation the bill to
pass Gregory Sant from the minority of
the committee chair recogniz
representative
mistake good afternoon colleagues I
don't want to be the post lunch buzzkill
but I want to say that one of the
biggest threats facing are the economic
value the health and the GU quality in
New Hampshire are cyanobacteria blooms
and the incidence of them is increasing
every year last summer there were 60
66 warnings affecting 43 water bodies
resulting in a loss of recreational days
or days under warning of 700 and sorry
you guys I should have my glasses 799
days and although the prevalance of
blooms affecting Lake winnus garnered
the most public attention most toxic
blooms impact smaller bodies of water
like Emerson pond in ringe and Arlington
Mill Pond in
Salem this summer New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
predicts this will be the worst summer
as far as number and duration of toxic
blooms and it's impossible for the state
to implement mitigation projects for
every water body
impacted but we can enable communities
to take on these projects on their own
in fact since
1849 New Hampshire has allowed
municipalities to form Village districts
to address very specific issues these
could range from fire response sidewalk
installation sewer maintenance and
supplying Municipal Water there are
presently 100 Village districts
operating in the state of New Hampshire
set up for a specific purpose
there are 14 of these purposes in
statute and House Bill
332 asks to add one more add a 15th
reason to form a village district and
that is to protect and remediate surface
waters let's face it the state and
specifically
Dees does not have the resources to
mitigate all toxic blooms occurring
throughout the state but that should not
not stop local communities from doing it
on their own by forming a village
District to protect and remediate their
Lakes especially those lakes and ponds
residing in more than one
municipality local communities can move
ahead with mitigation projects without
waiting for the state to spend state tax
dollars and money that may not
come those opposed to this bill claim
that it adds a another layer of
government not true Village districts
while having to comply with local and
state laws act independently of state
and local government they can be formed
they must be formed with a majority vote
of each and every town that seeks to be
part of a village District if those
towns vote to form the district the
district Commissioners the budget any
ordinances Etc must be approved by the
voters within that district and their
decisions are limited to only what
protects and remediates water as far as
the concern about taxation imposed by a
village District I would much rather
have a voter in a village District
approve and pay for its own water
projects then for a tax to be imposed on
the rest of us or by using state revenue
HB 332 is the essence of true local
control it enables communities to decide
if and how to solve their own problem
without having to wait on the state for
help help which may never come so I ask
you to please vote red vote away this
itl motion so that another motion can be
made that gives local control to those
people closest to the problem and more
able to solve it thank you very much
harb thank you Mr
Speaker government efficiency we heard
that mentioned this morning during the
governor's speech HB
332 which allows for the establishment
of a village District to protect and
remediate surface waters adds another
layer of government where the state
already has the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental resources to care for
our water quality and enforcement the
committee it was suggested that there
are other better methods of obtaining
cooperation between towns such as zoning
amendments we do not need to create
another layer of government which could
possibly increase taxes for those owning
waterfront
property testimony was received by a
resident of the town of Newbury located
on Lake sopi water shed they stated that
the smart protective policies
implemented by local town government
local town
government was the preferred method of
creating meaningful protective actions a
similar Bill HB 1250 did not pass this
house last year please support the
majority vote of itl on this Bill thank
you rung has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded it isic officially seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is a majority
committee report of itl on House Bill
332 this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative Sergeant for a
thank you Mr chair if I know that toxic
cyano bacteria blooms past contamination
and Wastewater runoff pose increasing
threats to New Hampshire's lakes and
rivers and if I know that this bill
simply provides local voters with the
option to create a village District to
protect shared surface waters and if I
know that New Hampshire's lakes rivers
and watersheds are powerful economic
engines driving tourism property values
and local businesses would I now vote no
and push the red button so another
motion can be made chair recognize re s
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the state already has the Department of
Environmental Services that can care for
water quality
enforcement if I know that policies can
be implemented by local town government
and if I know that creating another
layer of government may increase taxes
and cause loss of Rights of property
owners on the water would I not push the
green button to support the majority
vote of itl on this Bill thank you
motion before us is a majority committee
report of inexpedient to legisl on House
Bill 332 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos to press the red
button gring stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
motion majority committee on resources
Recreation development to which was
referred House Bill 334 FN act relative
to the comprehensive State development
plan considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate sen of
Ron dun for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to with the majority Report with
the recommendation of Bill a to pass
representative will Derby from the
minority of the committee representative
grer has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is any speeding to
legislate on House Bill
334 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you press a red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also tend to stay the vote
adopted Jo the committee on resource
Recreation and development to which was
referred House Bill 422 FN enact
increasing penalties for violations of
the Shoreland and water quality
protection act consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate Senator Tanya Don LEF for
majority of the committee minority of
the committee been considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass Gregory sjin for the
minority of the committee chair
Rome thank you Mr Speaker I know it's
only been a few minutes since I got to
speak to you about the dangers of
cyanobacteria blooms but I don't want
you to miss another opportunity to help
our state address this growing problem
first a bit of history back in
1991 the shoreline water quality
protection Act was passed into law the
first sentence of its purpose reads the
general court finds that the shore lands
of this state are among the most
valuable and fragile natural resources
and their protection is essential to
maintain the Integrity of public
Waters the ACT goes on to describe many
behaviors and actions that violate our
public Waters and it states that quote
upon Petition of the Attorney General or
of the municipality in which the
violation occurred the Superior Court
May Levy upon a person violating this
chapter a civil penalty in the amount
not to exceed
$5,000 for each continuing
violation end quote it goes on to say
the commissioner after notice and
hearing pursuant to RSA 51 541 colon a
May impose an administr a fine of up to
$5,000 for each
offense all HB 422 does is to adjust the
maximum fine to
$115,000 which in today's dollars is far
closer to what
$5,000 was worth in 19
1991 it doesn't compel the court or Dees
to fine at that level but it gives them
latitude to get there when the offense
is especially damaging to our
environment you'll hear the argument
that Dees hasn't issued a fine in over
12 years well those of you that were
here last term may remember that we
fixed language in that statute which
prevented enfor enforcement from
occurring that fix plus updating the
maximum level of fines that's in this
bill will serve as a strong deterrent
for those who think they can violate our
Waters without
consequence as I've said before toxic
cyanobacteria blooms pose a grave danger
to our Lake economy our health and the
quality of our environment HB 422
provides a meaning ful deterrent to
lessen the threat of toxic cyanobacteria
blooms and other outcomes arising from
Shoreline damage please vote red to vote
down the itl motion so that another
motion can be made thank
Donley thank you Mr
Speaker I would like to talk about many
of things that that uh representative
Rong just actually spoke about I agree
with most everything that she shared one
of the most UN disturbing things that I
found Doran committee was how
unjustified the increase was basically
because there was no fines for the last
decade so raising fines from 5 to5 was
an assumption rather than based on
datadriven analysis of past fines NHD
did share the last find they issued was
in 2013 the proposed fine increase
appears disproportionate and considering
the number of fines Dees has enacted
over the past decade I would encourage
us to let's see how this works out we
just passed legislation that actually
started in January 1 that the language
modification empowers Dees to pursue
violators who fail to make good faith e
efforts to damage public waterways
within violation I'm a big believer in
let's do education over legislation for
making change and this bill makes an
assumption that the increase will
promote compliance versus actually fine
violators to curb their violations to
secure the shoreline and water quality
protection and as she mentioned yes
there is a contained provision that
multiplies the penalty by a factor of
two for every violation that has not
been conformed to so I do encourage
people to support the itl and let's let
our legislation from last year actually
move forward and let's see how this
actually works and we actually pursue
violators instead of just threatening
them representative rung has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is the majority
committee report been Expediting to
legislated on House Bill
422 this is a roll call vote chair
recognize representative Bixby for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Mr
Speaker if I know that Dees usually
encourage is compliance with the
shoreline water quality protection act
through carrots but sometimes it needs
the threat of a stick to enforce
compliance and if I know that the
effective size of that stick the maximum
fine level has been reduced by 34 years
of inflation and if I know that
returning that stick to its original
proportional size requires increasing
the maximum fine from $5,000 to
$15,000 would I push the red button so
another motion can come forward thank
you chair recn representative dony for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the Department of enironmental Services
has not been consistently finding
violators for the last decade it rises
the question about effectiveness of the
empty threats and versus enforcement and
updating penalties if I know without
solid data to support the Assumption
behind the bill I challenge whether the
proposed increase fines would generally
actually improve the compliance without
enforcing
and if I know starting January 1 this
year the changes to the RSA updating the
shoreline quality protection act RSA
which now allows DS to submit fines
within the year will generate the buzz
amongst the lak front owners and Dees
will be able to enforce these penalties
to take to tackle blatant violators what
I press the green button for the
it the motion before us is the majority
committee report of an expedent legisl
House Bill 422 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
motion committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred Senate
Bill four an act relative to commercial
property assess clean energy
resiliency having considered the same
report the same with a recommendation to
build lot of passs from sen Michael vot
from majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having consider of the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate pres of Michael
Harington from the minority of the
committee the motion before us is the
motion to ought to pass on Senate Bill
four are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I oppose nay the
adopted committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
is referred House Bill 55
en act repealing The Selective Service
compliance act having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment to
Michael Moffett for the committee the
amendment is 0174 H printed in house
record 11 page 29 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I I oppos nay the eyes have
it amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those favor say I I oppose nay you
adopted the committee on state and
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
to which was referred House Bill 64 act
relative to extending hiring preferences
for military members and their spouses
to the state and private businesses and
establishing purchase preferences for
disabled veterans military spouses
regarding State Supply purchases
considered the same report the same of
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sen of Michael Mofford for the
committee the question is the ought to
pass motion on House Bill 64 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted majority of the committee on
state and federal relations and Veterans
Affairs to which was referred
hcr8 actor urging Congress to find that
the piscatqua river in Portsmouth Harbor
lie within the state of New Hampshire
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass sen of Tom Manion from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Christine Sebert for the
minority of the committee J recognizes
Speaker
sorry I Rise to you today to urge you to
vote against urging Congress to find the
Pasqua River in Portsmith Harbor lies
within the state of New
Hampshire we believe this is an
interstate issue that our governor is is
definitely fully capable of
addressing um we believe it is important
due to the vital of the waterways at
hand that we keep an open dialogue and
are able to work together on these
particular issues and find Solutions
thank
Barton thank you Mr
Speaker uh I rise in support of this
this resolution which uh reaffirms a
simple and crucial truth that the
piscatqua river and Portsmith Naval
Shipyard belong within the legal
historical boundaries and borders of the
great state of New Hampshire uh for
centuries Portsmouth Naval Shipyard has
been the Cornerstone of our state's
economy uh it's been a beacon of
innovation and a testament to our deep
Maritime
Heritage it was established in 1800
uh the shipyard has served our nation
with distinction uh building and
maintaining vessels uh that protect all
of our
freedoms uh it has provided generations
of hardworking granted Staters with the
Ste steady employment and has
strengthened our SE Co communities um
yet despite these facts there have been
a dispute over jurisdiction uh
particularly regarding the piscatqua
river uh and the land which on uh the
shipyard sits CV Island uh I want to be
perfectly clear history geography and
the law are on New Hampshire's side on
this and it's well documented um by
Senator Bob Smith's report from I
believe 1998 all of the documentation as
to where New Hampshire's border lies
with the the colony of Massachusetts is
across the street with the Attorney
General's office uh because in 2005 a
very similar resolution was passed uh
with overwhelming bipartisan support
support this resolution um mirrors that
uh there's no there's no reason why a
single member of this house should
really be against this resolution um it
affirms uh what was stated in that 2005
resolution the only difference is it EXA
it asks for the executive branch of the
federal government to issue an executive
order that would designate the duty
stations and the billets of Portsmith
Naval Shipyard uh as justly in Portsmith
New New Hampshire um and would relieve
our citizens of improper and unnecessary
uh taxes uh to the state of
Maine uh it further asked the federal
delegation of which consists of of
Senator Shaheen who is very supportive
of this resolution in 2005 as Governor
uh to enact legislation that would
properly Define what we have always
maintain to be true in our state um and
it's just as we own the Connecticut
River to the high water mark on the
Vermont Shore so do we own the piscatqua
river to the high water mark of the
former Massachusetts
colony uh let's Stand United in support
of this resolution let us send a clear
message that New Hampshire's history
economy sovereignty deserve unwavering
recognition and let us continue to honor
the legacy of those who have uh worked
in those Waters that worked at the the
shipyard that defend our nation uh and
continue to contribute to the greatness
of of our state uh please vote green on
hcr8 thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority committee report of autop pass
on C
hcr8 are you ready for the question
division a division has been requested
C
the motion before us a majority
committee report of Auto pass on hcr8
this is a division vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
changing the border and extending court
costs to revisit this decision does not
easily fit with within the current
budget and if I know that this kind of
Border change would open New Hampshire
to potential unknown costs for roads
Bridges and traffic control and finally
Mr Speaker if I know that this has
already been reviewed by the Supreme
Court and the current border lies or the
current
border um solution was agreed upon by
both States
involved then would I press the red
button to overturn the OTP and so
another motion can be made thank you
chair recognize representative Tom
Manion for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire has always
had jurisdiction and control over the
whole of the PC piscatqua River and if I
know the legislative boundary Commission
of October 29th 2004 final report stated
that the river is not patrolled in laws
are not enforced in a manner that
ensures that the people of New Hampshire
utmost security and protection and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that
thousands of granite Staters in the Sea
Coast region are negatively affected by
the incorrectly defined boundary today
then would I press the green button to
adopt the majority committee report of
OTP on
hcr8 motion before before is majority
committee report of autop pass on hcr8
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 250 voting yay 123 voting aay the
adopted majority of the committee on
state and federal relations and Veterans
Affairs to which was referred
noisy an act urging United States to
reject compliance with the European
Union's corporate sustainability due
diligence directive having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
reprentative Mike beler for the majority
of the committee minority having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that it's
expedient to legislate F from the
minority of the committee the chair
F thank you Mr
Speaker if my colleagues have read the
majority report or the text of the
resolution itself or watched our
committee discuss
hcr9 they've probably heard a lot of
talk about the contents of the the
corporate sustainability due diligence
csdd so they may have heard that the
regulations might be overreach by the
European Union but I am here to say the
text of the resolution doesn't matter
not the human rights protections not the
supposed Dei requirements which I
suspect must be a misunderstanding since
the
csdd explicitly advocates for
merit-based hiring and promotions in
Annex
one and not the environmental
regulations but whether you ran on a
platform of drill bab drill or your
campaign literature was just a print out
of the lyrics to Big Yellow Taxi we
should all be against this
resolution there's context that has
largely been missing from this debate
and it's that these regulations are an
inherent aspect of international trade
the CFR the code of f Federal
Regulations has an entire section on
standards for importing meat into the
United States there are offices in the
executive branch that exist just to help
companies navigate foreign trade
regulations and intercede if companies
find said regulations too
burdensome this isn't EU overreach it's
a global
economy what would be overreach would be
Congressional interference hcr9 urges
Congress to reject compliance with the
csdd but they can't do that they aren't
a party to it it's a relationship
between private business businesses and
the EU and businesses want to trade with
the EU it is some of the wealthiest
consumers in the world and it's much
easier and cheaper for them to just
standardize their entire process than
adjust for different International
standards depending on where the
products are
going but to quote Lavar Burton you
don't have to take my word for it an
attorney for one of those entities Reach
Out to me personally
unprovoked with a letter from
corporations including Unilever Nestle
and Mars in support of the
csdd but say congress did decide to
intervene what could they do tariffs the
EU announced Tuesday that they're
willing to impose retaliatory tariffs
[Music]
exor Manchester London Derry Jaffrey
Portsmith Hillsboro Hudson Rochester
Salem Hanover marac Belmont hookit
Lebanon and any town with a Hanford all
of those towns are home to locations of
companies that are either headquartered
in the EU or depend on business with the
EU I don't think any of us want to tell
our constituents that the reason they
lost their jobs is because this body
decided to start a trade War
but the biggest reason to reject hcr9 is
this the European commission is meeting
this month or the next and is expected
to loosen the standards in the
csdd hcr9 would antagonize one of our
largest trading partners over
regulations that might not even exist in
a
month hz9 is
untimely Reckless and does not serve the
citizens of New Hampshire I urge this
body to overturn the OTP and find this
bill an expedient to legislate thank you
and I call for a division
Bernardi thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to
support this resolution to reject the EU
cssd which I agree is untimely and
Reckless it was passed last summer all
the European countries have a
requirement to put this directive into
their own National laws and compliance
starts in
2027 it
incorporates 89 European standards and
international agreements some of which
we probably agree on no child labor no
SL SL slave labor compliance with the
Geneva Convention these are all good
things but in incorporates multiple ESG
standards in this
directive
e compliance with the Paris climate
Accord every covered business must meet
Net Zero by
s this is compliance with all the
Europeans Dei requirements the Europeans
wage and work standards the Europeans
Health standards including the World
Health Organization
regulations governance it bans free
speech on any communication that's
considered contrary to the Europeans
adopted climate change
policy all the covered parties the
covered parties that uh to which this
apply start with large businesses that
have over a half million dollars worth
of sales in the EU
but worse it applies to all their
contractors
suppliers and uh Partners upstream and
downstream so Nestle was mentioned
Nestle buys a lot of its sugar from
sugar beat manufacturers in North Dakota
they're going to have to comply with all
those
standards in New Hampshire we have
Electronic Component manufacturers that
are selling to Ford Mercedes whoever and
again all those smaller suppliers are
swept in because they are buying or
selling or working with a larger
manufacturer so these covered companies
must meet all these 89
standards and again including their
suppliers and if they cannot if those
smaller companies they work with can't
meet them then the larger companies are
required to pay for their compliance
if you do not meet these standards
you're subject to a 5%
annual um fee of of your net revenue in
the EU or you have to stop selling in
the
EU so this resolution basically asked
the federal government and I'm assuming
this is going to be the executive branch
to tell the EU that we do not
Support Compliance with their directive
mandates on American
businesses we suspect or I suspect this
may trigger the t-word
tariffs it's worked very well so far and
I suspect it will work this time as
well the Trump Administration has
already said no to most of these ESG
requirements for government purposes
this resolution asked the the executive
department to say no for American
businesses press green
please representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass on HCR
r nine this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative f for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that almost all of the
standards in the csdd have been agreed
upon by the United States if I know that
there are no Dei Provisions in here
there are
explicitly anti- Dei Provisions in here
if I know that businesses want this and
are asking the European commission not
to water down the regulations if I know
that suppliers and small and medium
Enterprises that feed into these large
corporations are not required to comply
with them and cannot be fined explicitly
it is in the
law and if I know that tariffs would
harm American Consumer s because the
European Union has plenty of other
potential trading partners if I know
that complicating res uh uh relations
the member will suspend this is a
parliamentary inquiry not a
speech thank you if I know all of that
would I press the red button chair
recognizes representative Bernardi for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I know Americans do not want
to be forced to comply with European
governance standards would I push the
green
button the motion the motion before us
majority committee report of Auto pass
on hcr9 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
while members present have an
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
vote 204 voting a 163 voting aay the
adopted committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred hr11 an act urging the
United States government to investigate
allegations of abuses of minorities
especially Hindus Buddhists Christians
and other religious minorities by the
interim government of Bangladesh we
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
Passa of Christine Sebert for the
Khan good afternoon Mr Speaker good
afternoon my colleagues my name is Abul
Khan I represent Seabrook and here I am
before you to talk about my native
country
Bangladesh I was uh immigrated to United
States 45 years ago I have many friends
and relatives living in Bangladesh and I
I was a frequent visit visitor of my
birth
country but last August 5th 2024
everything changed in that beautiful
country a fundamentalist student
Uprising took over over the country's
power and installed a pro-
fundamentalist anti-west
anti-india and anti everything
government led by Muhammad
eunus last 6 months the country has been
in a political turmoil lots of attacks
are reported targeting homes and
businesses of the opposition party
properties and places of worship and
religious minorities mainly Hindus
Buddhist Christians and IND indigenous
people five years ago the uh five days
ago they
bulldogged uh the Bangladesh father of
the nation's home which used to be a
museum they they are in a rampage all
over the country and I'm getting
frequent calls to let the policy makers
in the United States to to let them know
that what is happening in the small
country in Southeast Asia on November
5th a well-known Hindu an iscon
religious monk named chinmoy krishno
Dash was arrested under false
accusation and detained without any Bell
uh proceedings or any any you know until
this day his fault was that they alleged
that he was um disrespected the flag of
the
country even it's not considered a big
crime in all over the world
out of 150 Parliament members of
Bangladesh nearly 135 members houses
were either burned destroyed or
vandalized by this government supported
fundamentalist or so-called student mob
Mr Speaker honorable member for many
years Bangladesh Army were deployed by
United Nations for peacekeeping purpose
all over the world now the question is
if they cannot keep peace in their own
country how they can fulfill their job
as a peacekeeper and supported by our
tax dollar Mr Speaker there's a huge
issue in this part of the world their
are educational institution called
madrasas these student thugs are
educated in those madrasas by The
jihadist Who promote fundamentalism and
spreading hatred and lawlessness in the
country and many other part of the world
Mr Speaker current currently there is no
Law and Order and no de democracy in the
in Bangladesh no freedom of press the
government is arresting journalist who
does Fear sincere and independent
reporting about the current event those
fundamentalist
are uh dictating the courts and law
enforcement agencies in their own way I
would like I would also like to mention
that since last August Uprising those
fundamental skills about more than
thousand police officers in conclusion
I'm urging all my colleagues please vote
Yes on hr11 so we can can send this
resolution to united state government to
look into this and investigate this
continued Massacre happening right now
as I
speak thank you Mr Speaker and God bless
America and God bless State of New
Hampshire
the motion before us is the autopass
hr1 a Division has been requested
the motion before us is UT to pass on HC
on HR 11 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Buddha Taki
Mr Speaker honorable colleagues I rise
in strong support of hr11 because
complicity sorry if I
know
that that what's going on in Bangladesh
at this time is human rights violations
and
abuse and if if if I know that we need
to stop what's going on there I would
urge you to vote Yes on this resolution
thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass on hr1 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposer press the red
button warning stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote 328 voting a 41 voting a the motion
is
adopted for what member does a reason is
a member rise Mr Speaker I would like to
place the debate in the permanent
you majority the committee on
environment and agriculture to which is
referred House Bill 201 FN
an act prohibiting the removal of Claws
from cats having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate for senent of Judy Aon from
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Nicholas German from the minority
of the
committee chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker like my eloquent
friend from Amherst this morning I feel
a sense of deja vu giving this speech uh
this is one of the first speeches I gave
in this body about two years ago uh and
we passed that bill with a solid
bipartisan support I hope we can do the
same
today some of uh my friends who are
opposed to this bill talk about it as if
it were an intervention into who a
sacred doctor patient relationship let's
be clear about something this is not a
doctor patient relationship this is a
relationship between a veterinarian and
the patient in this case is a cat and if
we gave cats a choice I'm pretty sure
that they would in fact support this
legislation what this bill does is it
leaves open the possibility for medical
discretion it does a veterinarian can
say that there are legitimate medical
reasons why this procedure has to be
done and that is entirely permissible
within the bill so it is not an
intrusion in that relationship it is not
taking away the ability of veterinarians
to make the best medical uh decisions
for the patient which is the cat I would
also point out that the centers for dis
Disease Control for some time now has
not advocated the declawing of cats for
people who have certain autoimmune
disorders or certain disorders related
to blood blood clotting in fact removing
a CL cat's claws make it more likely to
bite which is a far greater danger to
the health of the owner than cat
scratches are our committee heard a lot
of testimony from members of the public
as well as Veterinary professionals that
this continues to be despite talk about
how things supposedly have evolved over
the past 30 or 40 years it continues to
be simply an inhumane procedure and it
should not be permitted in the state of
New Hampshire thank
you chair recogniz of Representative
Judy
Aaron thank you Mr
Speaker welcome back dear house
colleagues to our what seems to be my
neem cat
fight I rise today to ask that you vote
Yes to itl this bill hb21 one which
would ban the deying of cats in New
Hampshire and codify criminal penalties
for veterinarians who perform this
procedure in reality this bill is a
solution in search of a problem the
majority in this committee voted to itl
this bill because there is no real need
to ban this procedure or codify harsh
penalties to
veterinarians we do not have any stati
statistics that demonstrate that New
Hampshire has a problem with our
veterinarians performing cat declin
procedures for non-medical reasons
Additionally the criminal penalty in
this bill is really
unenforcable who could prove that a
veterinarian did a declaw without a
valid medical reason New Hampshire
veterinarians should not have to worry
about being accused of Performing this
or any other procedure
we heard testimony from New Hampshire
veterinarians that the overwhelming
majority of New Hampshire veterinarians
already discourage or do not offer cat
decline procedures and instead work with
cat owners to use behavior modification
and other techniques to prevent the cat
from scratching family members or
destroying property when those
techniques fail and the veterinarian
determines that declawing is the only
remaining solution aside from rehoming
or
euthanasia then that should remain a
choice between the cat owner and the
veterinarian if an owner has tried all
methods available to cease chronic
scratching and if deying was made
illegal their options would be to
abandon the cat rehome it to an
unsuspecting home or Surrender it to a
shelter or they might even take their
cat to a state where declawing is not
banned we heard in testimony that cat
declaw procedures are only done by New
Hampshire veterinarians when medically
necessary for the cat or for instances
when cat owners have medical conditions
that could be life-threatening or if
they're by like if they're scratched by
their cats and if they're on blood
thinners it does
happen it's an absolute last resort to a
chronic cat scratching Behavior we also
heard that modern techniques such as
laser surgery yield better and much
safer results than techniques used in
the past and that declawed cats can and
do live long healthy and happy lives
it's well known that certain animal
activist organizations are flooding the
state legislatures across this country
with these types of bills and once they
get one procedure banned they continue
to come back and try and ban others and
they use these campaigns specifically to
fund
raise lastly and most
importantly the majority of our
committee felt very
strongly and I'm going to say this again
the majority felt very strongly that we
as a legislature should not go down the
road of removing autonomy from New
Hampshire veterinarian
and dictating to them what procedures
they can and cannot
offer our licensed veterinarians have
the knowledge the experience and the
wisdom to work with their clients to
determine what procedures are the right
ones for their pets and the legislature
should not interfere with that
relationship for all of these reasons
and more the majority in the committee
voted to itl this bill and I ask you to
pre please join us and press the green
button and vote this bill in expedient
to legislate so that cat owners and
their veterinarians can together
continue to be able to make legitimate
appropriate and informed choices in New
Hampshire I thank you very much for all
of your attention and Mr Speaker I ask
for a division
vote a division vote has been requested
members take your seats this will be a
the motion before us is the majority
commit report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill
2011 this is a division
vote chair recognizes representative H
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
practice of declaring cats is
inhumane which is why fish and game the
CDC and other reputable
organizations believe it should not be
allowed and if I know that despite its
being perhaps rare in New Hampshire
there is evidence that it's still being
done and if I know that the vet client
relationship will not be harmed in the
least by this bill's
passage and finally if I know Mr Speaker
that this bill does more than scratch
the surface but rather allows our feline
friends to scratch at will would I now
vote red so that a better motion can be
made thank you Mr
Speaker do I recognize representative C
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that for
the past six to eight years or three to
four terms we have heard the spill in
each and every time the same question is
asked how many cats are being declawed
and the answer is always the same we
don't
know and Mr Speaker if I know that the
majority of New Hampshire State
veterinarians do not declaw
cats and those that do that many of our
contacted the answer was I've decl one
cat in five years or two cats in 40
years
and Mr Speaker if I know that one of the
organizations pushing this bill has
threatened a Committee Member would I
now press the green
button house will be in
order the motion before us is majority
commit a report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
201 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
B members present had an opportunity to
vote 191 voting y77 voting a the motion
committee on Judiciary to which is
referred House Bill 369 FN act relative
to misdemeanor sexual assault
prosecutions having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation Bill l a
pass with Amendment pres of Caitlyn
kutab for the committee the amendment is
0167 printed in house record 11 page 32
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those n the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I iose
nay the amendment is adopted a motion
the motion is
justice chair recognizes a member from
Auburn for a third reading motion thank
you resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session being in order at
the present time that the reading of
bills be by title only and resolutions
by caption only and that all bills
ordered a third reading be read a third
time by this resolution and that all
titles of bills be the same as adopted
and that they be passed at the present
time and when the house adjourns today
it be to meet Thursday February 20th at
10:
a.m. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppose nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
Murray thank you Mr Speaker um members
of the progressive caucus or if anyone
is interested in learning more about the
progressive caucus we are meeting now
post session over at the L in rooms
20224 um if you have any questions come
see me thank
Simpson thank you Mr Speaker stay work
play New Hampshire is holding a
legislative reception at 4:30 this
afternoon from 4:30 to 6:30 at hotel
conquer that's on 11 South Main Street
here in conquer the reception will take
place in the New Hampshire room so
bringing together legislators young
Granite Staters and those who employ
them this casual networking event will
give you the opportunity to meet younger
constituents and learn more about the
issues affecting whether they might stay
in or leave New Hampshire thank you
leori thank you Mr Speaker we have a big
announcement to share with the body
today yes very big huge bigly a
beautiful announcement a very beautiful
announcement the legislative Golf
Classic will be back June 23rd at
wonderful Lowden Country Club and I
would say we're going to make this
legislative Golf Classic great again but
it's already great as those of you
who've been there know yes indeed at our
last classic in
2023 we raised over
$20,000 thanks to many of you to help
Liberty house in Manchester which helps
homeless and transitioning veterans the
course should be in great shape
by June 23rd and we're hoping for Skies
that are Bluer Than California and
Greenland there's going to be there'll
be a shotgun St at 8:30 830 a.m. on June
23rd shotgun start shotgun no worries
whoever fires a shotgun will be a
verified NRA member all right so does
Lowden still have gas powered golf carts
or are they EV now again representative
I have some bad news and some good news
the bad news is that Lowden still has
gas powerered carts the good news is
that you can again buy carbon credits
for $50 from honest Mike moffit's carbon
credit
store and I will plant a tree for every
credit there you go all right that that
is great news I guess also great news is
that the legislative Golf Classic is
inclusive young and old red and blue
purple and orange we even have a bunch
of lobbyists who had a great who had a
lot of fun last time so all are welcome
all are welcome but uh to include
Senators well let's see it how it goes
with the uh Committee of conferences and
how much they fo upon us this year
speaking of red and blue Lowden has uh
red teas and blue te's uh how about if
the Republicans tee off from the red
teas and the Democrats from the blue te
te um just to make it interesting yeah
well aren't the red teas a lot closer to
the green what's your point well how
about if we all play from the white teas
in the interest of equity and
fundamental fairness I could support
that I suppose assuming the majority
leader
approves I see no reaction by the way
[Laughter]
um so mark your calendars June 23rd lden
Country Club there will also be fun
contests raffle prizes putting
competitions longest drive nearest to
the pin and if you get a hole in one you
win a Prius a Prius how about a how
about a pickup
truck uh I'm looking behind us for
guidance on
that none well uh if you're not a golfer
you're still welcome to come back to the
Social and socialize and have lunch and
buy raffle tickets and get into the
putting
contest yeah so we're finishing up here
so uh that'll be awesome uh big
beautiful prizes come to the social
participate in the putting contest by
raffle tickets and uh that's about it uh
M representative so if you want to play
or help out just let myself
representative Moffett know you can take
up we can take up to 36 teams uh and if
we haven't sold out in advance we'll
offer even same day registration who
same day registration same day
registration I only hope we don't have
busloads of Massachusetts golfers coming
up
[Music]
here thank you representative I'm sure
it'll be just fine so mark your
calendars again June 23rd for the
legislative Golf Classic at Lowden
Country Club and yes indeed for those
who might be interested there is a 19th
Hole thanks everybody thank you Mr
Speaker
[Music]
chair recognize the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker uh couple of announcements one
uh Please be aware that legislative
license plates um have been delayed uh
some have come in most have not uh
please watch your email from the uh
House communications email to notify you
when your plates are available for
pickup here at the state house not at
VMV but here um also
please clean out your seat Pockets after
session take your trash with you if you
have
it and please clean out your mailboxes
and do not leave food or beverage in
you chair recognizes represent SE league
thank you very much um Mr Speaker um and
colleagues today I Rise We rise
collectively and anyone else is welcome
to join us for Memorial remarks for The
Honorable Emma Rouse who served this
body from 2002 to
2010 six of those years as the chair of
the education
committee prior to the legislature Emma
also taught English at Oyster River High
School for 20 years
on February 1st Emma passed away after a
year and a half battle with cancer but
more than her dedication to service in
the schools and in this body Emma was
involved in many areas of the community
including her synagogue various farming
groups environmental causes and so much
more she was also one of the very first
people that I met when I came to New
Hampshire she soon became a dear friend
and a member of our
family Emma approached the world with
curiosity deliberativeness and and
kindness and especially as tomorrow's
Valentine's Day I invite you to hold
those values
dear she was truly a treasure and she
made a mean apple
pie I'd like you to all please join me
in a moment of silence for the late
I'd like to make a motion State your
motion go could we have the remarks
printed in the permanent journal without
objection thank you chair recognize
thank
you thank you Mr Speaker and honorable
colleague
for allowing me to speak with you
today today is February
13th my math is correct yesterday was
the
12th tomorrow's the
14th I'm taking this time to honor
two wonderful patriotic
Americans whose
birthdays were on the 12th 12 and the
14th of
February these two
Americans one of which I know you all
know
well and the other maybe not so well had
a profound impact on this
country the
first there a gentleman here over my
right shoulder Abraham
Lincoln I know you all know Abraham
Lincoln
background his family was were farmers
was born in Kentucky moved to Indiana
and ended up in Illinois very close to
where I grew up in
Illinois he hated farming he wasn't cut
out for it so as soon as he was able to
leave the farm at 18 he got out of there
he moved to a little Community called
New
Salem and in his formative years he was
a storkeeper
he was a soldier in the Blackhawk
War he was a
surveyor just as a personal note he
surveyed the town where my farm was
he ended
up becoming a
politician he was elected to the
Illinois House of Representatives for
four
terms and then to the US Congress for
one term the only wig from the state of
Illinois the end of one term he got out
of there in the meantime he had studied
formal education he didn't go to law
school but he passed the bar and became
an
outstanding very successful
attorney in the state of Illinois if you
know the Illinois Central Railroad he
was their attorney so he made a lot of
in
the election for Senator in
1858 he ran against Stephen A Douglas
and he had a series of debates the
Lincoln Douglas debates very
famous he made a great name for himself
but he lost that election in
1860 he ran for
president as a
Republican and although he got only 40%
of the popular vote he was
1860 the United States was in utter
turmoil we were
divided
drastically by the whole issue of
slavery by the time
he was
inaugurated half the states had seceded
from the Union
situation the other person that I want
to honor that you might not know so much
about was Frederick
Douglas Frederick
Douglas was born a
slave he never knew who his father
was his mother was sold off when he was
very
young so he grew up in a terrible
situation he but he had a deep seated
teenager he tried to
escape one time he he they caught him
and brought him back beat him he tried
to escape again they caught him and
brought him back and beat him
again the third time he
North and became a
celebrated
speaker and
printer he became acquainted with
William Lloyd Garrison Who was the the
publisher of the leading abolitionist
newspaper in the
north and he from the time he went North
he became celebrated not just in the
north but all over the world he was a
abolition he never knew what his birth
date
was but he chose February
14th because the few times he saw his
mother she called him her little
Valentine so he chose 14th that February
14th as his
birthday so when Lincoln was
elected the South had
seceded the country was going going down
path the issue of slavery came up in
front of
Lincoln and
Lincoln was sort of an agnostic he hated
slavery but he he knew that he couldn't
slavery he he said very famously he said
if I could save the Union
by freeing the slaves all the slaves I
would do it but he said
also if I could save the
Union by not freeing a single slave I
also so after Lincoln was
inaugurated Frederick Douglas went to
Washington and broke in through a line
of off office Seekers and elbowed his
way to
Lincoln and bent his
ear and Lincoln was so taken by
Frederick Douglas that for the rest of
their
lives they
became terrific admirers of each
other and Lincoln knew that he could
not he could not eradicate slavery
but he worked with Douglas and Douglas
worked with
him and
together on January 1st
1863 Lincoln issued his Emancipation
Proclamation now for that we remember
Lincoln as he's the guy that freed the
slaves but that's not really true
because Lincoln only the Emancipation
only
applied to the
Confederacy it didn't apply to the to
the states that had slaves that were
loyal to the to the
union so as the as the
Union forces mve through the South and
liberated the South they liberated those
slaves and those slaves became free
but by the time the war was over there
were still about a half a million slaves
in the
US they were in the border states
Kentucky Maryland Delaware yes Delaware
was a slave state
but so there were a half a
Frederick Douglas was looking forward to
working with
Lincoln to get the job
done and
to give the
freed black former slaves an opportunity
to
participate in the in the real
America well that didn't
happen
Lincoln's life was taken as we all know
inauguration but Frederick
Douglas kept working at it kept working
at it and slavery was
finally
eradicated in the 13th Amendment to the
Constitution in December of
1865 and that's when slavery ended and
Douglas didn't stop
there the 14th and the 15th 15th
critical Douglas not only worked for the
freedom of of black folks but he also
worked for women's suffrage and and a
lot of people don't know that but he was
a leading proponent of women's suffrage
and was personal friends with Susan B
Anthony and the Anthony Family
family he delivered the eulogy
at Susan B Anthony's father's funeral
and they were buried
together
so he lived to be an old man he was 77
when he died have a heart attack after
attending a woman's sufferage
meeting a lot of people don't realize
this about Frederick Douglas but in the
the 19th century he was the most
photographed person in the world in the
19th
century so I ask you
today that we honor these two people who
are so very
important to our
history and that
we honor them and respect their memory
can
to complete the mission and make America
the best it can be for all Americans
[Applause]
[Music]
for what reason does member rise request
that the remarks of the previous speaker
be printed in the permanent journal
without
objection chair recognize representative
wheeler
thank you Mr
Speaker and thank you representative
lell for that amazing and thorough
history of this country and a call to
make this the best country that it can
be as it is in its spirit I rise
today for those of you who don't know me
my name is representative Jonah Orion
wheeler I represent the towns of petero
and Sharon and it's good to see all of
you here today and I apologize for
keeping us a little bit longer I want to
go home too I Rise with my friends the
three other African-American members of
this body in the middle of February to
Mark the Black History Month celebration
this is a tradition of the house in
which we read out the names of the black
members of this body who have served so
I'll do that and then give a little
statement and then we'll let you go
home so let's start with retired army
colonel the first man black man to get
elected to this body hry Boyd Richardson
of
1974 who served till
1978 then there was Lionel Johnson from
Manchester from 88 to 2004 Linda long
from nsha the first African-American
woman to be elected to this legislature
she was elected in ' 86 Juanita Bell
from nsha from
1998 Harvey key from nsha good friend
from 1998
Jackie Witherspoon from exiter from
1997 Chris Roberts of Kean from 2004 to
2016 James Lawrence of Hudson from 2002
to 2008 Melanie Lake from 2016 to 2010
and again in the 2012 bium Carol ET of
Plymouth from 2016 to 2008 Claire Clark
of bosin from
200 2000 to
2010 caroleta Alia from 2012 to 2018 and
then again from 2020 to
2022 my good friend Jean Judy from
Manchester 2005 to
now my good friend the longest serving
African-American woman in this body and
somebody who words don't describe the
public service that she has brought to
[Applause]
NASA Dean Ford of Manchester serving
from last year 2020 to
20 our new friend Mary nwanda georgees
anym all these people all of these
people about 18 19 of them laid the path
for a 19-year-old idealistic kid with a
lot of dreams and crazy hair to come to
this legislature and pass legislation
into law and as representative lell said
this country has gone through some very
tough times and there were people like
Martin Luther King and Elvis Presley who
had a dream that we would all live
together as one that black children and
white children would dance and sing and
be friends not as black children or
white children but as children amen that
people would be together as
people not black people or white people
but
people and I stand before you
today a 21-year-old with a lot of dreams
and energy to get them done as a
testament that those dreams are now a
reality
that I grew
up with a I didn't grow up with a white
mother I grew up with a mother I didn't
grow up with white friends or black
friends I grew up with friends and that
is the dream becoming a reality where we
can all look at each other as human
beings not through the divisions that
those with a lot of power are trying to
divide this country with but as human
beings working together to to advance
[Applause]
love there are so many of us out there
who have come to this body and it is an
honor Mr Speaker to be a
representative with so many people who
care so deeply about the state of New
Hampshire and those that would wish to
divide us using
lies political
ganship and all the divisive tactics
that we see from those who do not
believe in the Republic of the United
States of America and what it can be for
this country we stand all of us as a
testament that we will rise above those
lies deception and deceit and make the
United States of America the greatest
Republic this world has ever seen so
thank you very much Mr Speaker let's
bring about the 21st century an American
[Applause]
you what reason does a member rise I
Rise to make a motion to print the words
of the young gentleman with the great
objection representative wosman moves at
the house stand in recess for the
purpose of the introduction of bills
vacate motion enroll build amendments
enroll Bild reports and receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos n
the eyes have it house is in recess